Về cố quen phê dưới đấu thông màu lý chương Joe Brah, ở tình Kieu Bore Hơ Raq, đang xấu bất chiển khai đấu tiên của thần tài miên Bối Mỹ, kỳ hội của ý thần tư năm 2018.
Mọc Joe Brah là một trong những trữ lượng lý chương lần nhất của quen nè, mưa liệu cót lỏi trong sản xuất phin và công nghệ năng lượng sạch.
Dựa này được kỳ bọng sĩ trở thành hình màu đấu tư chung trong quy đấu tư tài thiết Mỹ của quen nè.
Theo thần Mỹ được quyền tiếp cận nếu tiền tới hơn 50% của quen nè.
Sòng kế vẫn giữ chuyển tài miên và là nhiều anh dưới được cá đồ tư tại chỗ trong ý nhất mới năm.
Mỗi xin tân xem đây là có hội chính lượng để giảm phụ thuộc và Trung Quốc trong chủi cùng ở vật liệu công nghệ cao.
Về phía của quen nè, hợp tăng này không chỉ mang lại 1 đốn mà có là đoàn bày để phục hồi kinh tế hậu chiến.
Và khẳng định vị thay cho quen hệ với Mỹ.
Tôi nhên những thích thực hiện hữu vẻ ăn ninh khạp tăng và quen khai thác,
vẫn là anh số lớn của môi nhoình đầu tư này.